Florida Governor Ron DeSanto standing up
to critics over his State Banning a new
AP African-American history class the
Biden White House is blasting the
decision
this course It is incomprehensible that
uh to see that uh this is what uh this
band or this block to be more specific
that DeSantis has put forward if you
think about the study of black Americans
that is what he wants to block uh and
and and again these types of actions
aren't new they're not new from from
what we're seeing especially from
Florida sadly DeSantis hitting back
saying the course would indoctrinate
students and has a political agenda
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda they're
advocating things like abolishing
prisons now that's a that's a radical
political position
Harold how do you see all of this
well
I would have thought that by now that
Governor DeSantis who I think is an
important probably one of the two or
three most important voices in politics
over the last two two to three years and
certainly when you think about covet was
was the most dynamic voice for those
opposing some of the things that uh that
the Biden Administration and even some
of the things that he's now opposing
what the Trump Administration did and
some of his questioning about the the
vaccines
but as I listen to him now and it
appears that he's a front-runner for the
presidency on the Republican side he
appears to be winning even against Joe
Biden in the election I would have
thought his he would have pivoted to
talking about China talking about our
military talking about the Border
talking about crime nationally
um so it's it's taken him down a little
notch in in my book second about this
issue I have young kids so this this
whole idea around what's happening in
schools and we're dealing with this
conversation at our school around when
kids should be taught certain things and
I I'm not totally persuaded yet that we
should be talking to kids at such an
early age about uh gender and sexuality
the way some of the schools want to talk
about but as I looked into this thing
that that what what he's talking about
uh DeSantis he's talking about authors
like James Baldwin and zor Neil Hurston
and Tony Morrison who make up some of
the most important writers in the 20th
century American Canon now if you want
to quarrel with the American Canon and
go back there growl and Poe and Herman
Melville both who died under suspicious
circumstances some they said they were
it was suicide or substance abuse or or
alcoholism I wouldn't say reading Edgar
Allan Poe means that you want to be an
alcoholic or you're trying to push
substance abuse on kids my only message
to him is get serious this that this is
not going to change outcomes of student
outcome performance in your States you
were 34th in 2018 and 2019 and you're no
higher today and it's not because you're
teaching black American studies or
African-American studies it's because
kids aren't learning science they're not
earning learning math they're learning
English I would agree with you some of
the things you talked about the
intersectionality thing you got to
figure that out but at the end of the
day student performance is the most
important thing and if it means teaching
them something you don't like governor
and they learn more then do it okay so
he's been DeSantis is being viciously
attacked on this particular issue no
one's talking and we should talk about
this issue I want you to Greg but the
other thing is doing is he just had a
big raise for teacher teachers proposed
which gets directly to
student performance on this issue when I
finally read all about it like he's not
saying you can't teach African-American
studies he's saying this particular
course go back to the drawing board
let's see something else yeah and I
think that's I think Harold you kind of
you you you did did a little fine line
there I think you actually were saying
the same thing yeah but be serious about
it it's a black I mean as you know I'm
an expert at black history I've been
teaching it for uh decades at uh the
University of Gutfeld studies internet
College uh but uh you know
um when you kind of get the sense that
they're shoehorning like activist type
stuff intersectionality queer Theory
transact into these things you got to
keep an eye on it you know and it's like
you know and so that what they're doing
for the average black family they should
be pissed they'll be like going this
isn't right this is an African-American
history this is created by some white
privileged
left-wing Elite you know and maybe a
black female Marxist who's their teacher
or something it's like it's like it's
not it doesn't reflect the the
conventional wisdom of most people I
came up with this Theory yesterday
purely by accident I call it these straw
trans argument like the straw man
argument but it's straw Trans in the
sense that anytime you bring up a
sensible idea like look I don't think
there should be invasive permanent
surgeries on healthy kids and I don't
think activists should be generating you
know sex or gender theory for children
that is perceived as transphobic so
that's that's what I would call a straw
man's argument when in fact being
pro-trans is making sure this stuff
doesn't happen so people are old enough
to make the decision so you can respect
respect and the whole idea of it and not
have to worry about this other stuff
which is basically being pushed by a
small group of uh delusional activists
judge Governor DeSantis knows that he's
going to get attacked for decisions that
he makes he seems prepared to respond
but the White House loves to have
DeSantis as a foil they absolutely do
I'm surprised they didn't drag out or he
didn't drag himself out Gavin Newsom who
who sees himself as the person to oppose
uh Rhonda Governor Ron DeSantis the the
thing about this is it's it's almost
like this indoctrination is parading
around his education I think we all
agree uh DeSantis wants black history
black education
um and what he said basically was I
don't want to talk about issues like
queer Theory and intersectionality and
abolishing prisons when the truth is
that we just learned two years ago that
the African-American Community more than
anyone wants more cops they want more
consequences and we're indoctrinating
our kids to say you know well the blacks
are against prisons no they're not so
and he's taking on this issue as opposed
to other issues Harold I think because
he's in the thick of it he got in the
thick of it because of Disney and what
they said about the don't say gay log
because we saw what happened in Virginia
uh and just today I forget what
Governor's new governor who's now has
the money following the students in her
State they just signed a law for yeah
Iowa in education so it's a big issue
and he's primed for it Dana can I just
add something to this real quick that
what we're seeing here is a lot like
what we when we covered the story about
the American doll book and it's like
what is this doing in this book about
the American doll when you go to that
store why are why are there chapters on
intersectionality be your own non-binary
to kids that's what all this is about
it's not about African it's about why is
why are these things showing up in
places they shouldn't where's the age
appropriateness Jesse's done a deep dive
here I have oh fantastic I read the
entire syllabus today you did it took me
about an hour okay
it was the most prep I've done for this
it's a very good course three quarters
of it is very rigorous and very good and
this is very high level stuff and then
you get to about 1960 in here and it's
all activism it's all ideology it's no
history a good course chunk of this is
really good stuff and then it goes into
white supremacy patriarchy
abolish the prisons overthrow capitalism
queer Theory intersectionality and
you're like whoa we were going pretty
good here and then boom it hit you with
all that stuff and I understand why some
African Americans want to take an
African-American history class that's
taught through the lens of African
Americans it's not some white guy
telling the history of African Americans
it's a black professor or whatever that
I understand that but now no one's read
this no one's read the syllabus
Jean-Pierre hasn't read it this is like
the don't say gay bill now they're
saying this is the you don't say black
belt in Florida so it's just being
totally mischaracterized and we're going
to have on the director of the Florida
education department tonight on prime
time to discuss it further and you know
what Jesse Jr has applied early decision
to Gutfeld University and he's been
accepted you know what the thing is
there are no favors I you know he just
got on in his own marriage good good
good he had an alias all right I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now